alright before we move on and there's
just so much craziness going on I do
want to remind you and give an update on
the crowdfunding campaign that we are
undertaking at david pakman.com slash
donate the david pakman show has existed
and grown for years because of the
support of the audience and because of
that we've gone from a show that was
once every other week to a show that was
once a week twice a week four times a
week and now a five-day-a-week daily
program and we're looking to take the
show to the next level and part of this
is going beyond just as i drop my pen
out of excitement part of this is going
beyond just media but also into
progressive activism so one of the
things we're doing with our current
campaign at david pakman.com slash
donate is looking to create a new
position called the progressive
engagement coordinator i won't bore you
with the details but it's fantastic and
you can read more about it at david
pakman.com slash donate we also are
raising money to do a truly professional
i would call it a studio redesign but
we've never really had a design to begin
with we just have basically a couple TVs
in a black curtain so i guess to do an
actual professional studio design and
i've started to get some of the
proposals pat from our studio design
expert that came in and it's just gonna
be such a head and shoulders upgrade for
us yeah it's fair to say that we are
creatively challenged so we're gonna
have to bring in some outside help on
that one ya gotta bring in the
professionals also the david pakman show
ready to launch on amazon prime we
finalized all of the logistics but we do
need additional staff resources to make
that happen also something that we are
fundraising for so so far we've raised
about 8,000 bucks from roughly 200
people the exact average donation uh is
thirty-five dollars the average donation
is thirty-five dollars we've had
donations as small as one dollar and as
big as four hundred and ninety-nine
dollars so my question to you can you do
roughly half of that average donation
instead $35 can you donate seventeen
dollars to the campaign if so go to
david pakman.com slash donate their a
couple different perks available at that
price level can you do nine dollars
because nine dollars is the level of our
first perk that is available if you can
do nine dollars please do a David
pakman.com slash donate and if you can
only do a couple of bucks please still
do it these small donations say they add
up I know it sort of sounds like obvious
that yes of course small donations add
up but what I mean is the cumulative
impact of those small two three four
dollar donations do get us closer to the
goal and can you best the current top
donation the current top donation is 499
dollars from Joshua can somebody do do
do five hundred dollars or 501 and
lastly if you can't do anything if you
really can't donate a single dollar
that's ok we have a referral contest the
top five refers to the david pakman show
fundraising campaign will get a two
hundred ninety nine dollar perk called
the total package as a whole bunch of
great david pakman show gear for free
currently the top two refers are
Jeremiah and florian Jeremiah and
florian currently the two top refers to
refer people just go to david pakman.com
slash donate and then use the Facebook
and Twitter buttons at the top of the
page and again all donations all perks
it's all happening at david pakman.com
slash donate